sa série n 5 un prodige de la
technologie et ça c'est l'erreur de
calcul qu'on fait les ingénieurs
aucune perte humaine heureusement mais
plusieurs millions de dollars partis en
fumée à cause d'un problème de maths
tous les jours des erreurs de calcul
sont faites avec des conséquences
tragiques
overdose de médicaments écroulement
d'immeubles ou même crash boursier
les mathématiques sont partout semblant
gouverner la totalité des événements de
l'univers heureux ou malheureux mais est
il possible que la base des
mathématiques humaines soient fausses et
si en réalité tout ce que nous
calculions se baser sur une
incompréhension des lois qui régissent
notre monde
il est probable que les calculs et
théorème que nous avons érigé comme
vérité universelle pourrait être des
erreurs qui mèneront à l'écroulement des
sciences d'ici quelques années
ça paraît fou mais vous allez voir avec
moi ma tarte ego accès beaucoup plus
troublant que vous ne le pensez les cinq
piliers des mathématiques en naviguant
sur internet c'est peut-être déjà tombés
sur ces soi-disantes preuve que un plus
un égale zéro comme sur cette vidéo à 9
millions de vues
ces raisonnements paraissent convaincant
mais un regarde en détail on voit bien
vite ou et embrouillé ici une division
par zéro
bah oui si à égal b à - belga 0 donc
c'est pas du tout légal de diviser comme
ça en fait il y a très peu de chance de
détruire l'édifice que sont les
mathématiques avec une vidéo facebook
car les maths sont une discipline
millénaire avec un édifice solide
c'est à la fois une qualité mais aussi
un défaut pour prouver un nouveau
théorème en mathématiques il faut le
construire à partir des théorèmes
trouvait précédemment
c'est pourquoi en maths au pourrait
construire de véritables arbre
généalogique des formules mathématiques
euclide mathématicien grec a été le
premier à essayer de le construire
concluant qu'il existait cinq ans être
primordiaux qui ont engendré tout les
théorème de géométrie
on les appelle les actions imaginez les
comme cinq brics sacré merdes et
mathématiques
ces cinq brics ont un peu l'adn de la
géométrie il suffit de les combiner
ensemble pour pouvoir aboutir à tous les
théorèmes existants ces axiomes les
voici
alors si vous voulez lire vous pouvez
faire pause car c'est dit de façon un
peu complexe mais croyez moi c'est des
évidences par exemple en reliant deux
pointus peut tracer un segment dire
qu'on peut tracer une ligne
deux points c'est quand même super
basique j'ai dit que les axiomes était
une évidence mais pas tout à fait il y
en a un qui va poser vraiment problème
aux mathématiciens et c'est le dernier
étant donné un point et une droite ne
passant pas par ce point il existe une
seule droite passant par ce point est
parallèle à la première et c'est loin
d'être aussi logique que ça en a l'air
déjà des droites parallèles cds droite
qui ne se croisent pas quand tu les
prolonger à l'infini et utiliser
l'infini ça pose souvent des problèmes
en mathématiques et ce n'est pas le dix
neuvième siècle qui va dire le contraire
car c'est à cause de ça car pans entiers
des mathématiques va s'effondrer dans
cette destruction interne que vous
connaissez très bien va prendre très
cher et c'est celui de pythagore et si
le théorème de pythagore était faux
l'homme qui va poignarder les
mathématiques en plein coeur c'est lui
car frédéric gosse mais dans le milieu
on l'appelle le prince des
mathématiciens
il n'est pas exagéré à trois ans le gars
courjault déjà son père pour qu'il se
trompe dans ce conte carlos va faire une
découverte qui remettra en cause un
théorème intouchable presque sacré ce
fameux et nous-mêmes de pythagore ce
truc serait faux et cool apprend à
l'école alors il faut avoir quelque
chose en mathématiques
on n'aime pas trop les théories trop
révolutionnaire en grèce antique les
grands mathématiciens avait des sectes
qui se battaient à mort au nom des
mathématiques
un des disciples de pythagore pour avoir
réussi à lui donner tort pour avoir
relevé l'existence des nombre
irrationnel aurait des noyés par ses
condisciples
c'est pourquoi gosses étaient horrifiés
par ces découvertes tellement qu'ils la
gardent à secrète pendant quelques temps
les deux gosses et de prendre le 5e
postulat à contre-pied jusque là tout le
monde disait qu'une seule parle elle
pouvait passer par ce coin moi je décide
que l'on existe une infinité ça te
paraît impossible
d'abord cela il te suffit d'une petite
astuce pour un peu ta feuille et la
droite rouge et bleu ne se couche jamais
elles sont donc parallèle et toutes les
droites rouge passe par le même point en
utilisant sa cinquième brive perso au
lieu des actions du clip gosses va
construire là
première jeu mépris non deux qui
viennent il va créer des structures
mathématiques inconnu jusqu'à alors et
devinez quoi
dans cette géométrie courbes et les
lignes droites tête qu'on les imagine
n'existent plus donc plus de triangle de
carrés et de cercle les racines carrées
qui les sinus caussinus et compagnie il
balaye tout va renverser un système
pourtant c'est qu'ils ne branlent abl
que pendant des siècles on avait affirmé
même dieu tout puissant est incapable de
contredire la géométrie d'euclide est
bien avec gosses c'est officiel le
mathématicien est plus puissant que dieu
les mathématiques ont appelé ces heures
sombres
la crise des fondements vous pensez que
c'est juste une représentation farfelu
de match fou ni géométrie non
euclidienne sont pourtant une réalité
que vous lui avez tous les jours et ce à
un homme que vous connaissez tout cela
bien compris quelques siècles plus tard
quand à steinbach montré que l'espace
temps et courbet l'idée de la feuille
pliée de gosse va se révéler très utile
pour comprendre le monde à stein va
affirmer sur la géométrie de gauche la
théorie de la relativité n'existerait
pas l'idée de la géométrie posé sur
papier place ça représente tellement pas
la réalité qu'une civilisation
supérieure trouverait peut-être ça
complètement primitif pythagore
néanderthal dé mathématiques vraiment en
fait les maths c'est juste un outil pour
décrire des choses donc ya pas vraiment
de géométrie justes ou fausses on a un
tournevis et un marteau ils marchent
tous les deux très bien et on s'en sert
seulement quand on en a besoin
sauf que toute cette histoire ça a
détruit l'universalité des maths c'est
un peu comme l infiniment petit
l'infiniment grand
tous les jours les scientifiques
essayent de trouver une théorie qui va
unir ces deux mondes pour décrire
l'orbité d'une planète où leurs beats
d'un électron autour d'un atom by a
aucun calcul aucun outil similaire et
pour plein de gens ben c'est pas normal
et ben c'est pareil pour les maths
gousse a lancé la quête du one piece une
grande aventure pour réunifier les maths
en cherchant à unifier les maps en les
encore plus détruite après la crise des
fondements il fallait tout reconstruire
il fallait que les mathématiciens
reviennent à la source à l'endroit même
de la naissance des mathématiques
je veux bien sûr parler des actions vous
rappeler à ces fameuses vérité
mathématique qu'on ne remet pas en
question et si justement on les rues
définissait pas question d'ajouter un
axiome à chaque fois qu'on constate un
manque un le but c'est pas de finir avec
40000 axiome originaux il faut donc
creusé et plus on creuse
plus on s'approche de quelque chose qui
est murmuré avec effroi parmi les
mathématiciens le principe explosion
si jamais on trouvait des actions qui
entraînait une minuscule contradictions
dans la théorie alors cette
contradiction contaminera toutes les
théories existantes du modèle
mathématique comme on l'a dit les
mathématiques qui ont une sorte d'arbre
généalogique chaque entreprise se
construit sur la théorie précédente
si on découvre une fissure à la base ce
n'est qu'une question de temps avant que
tout ce qu'on connaisse ses chromes le
c'est sûr se terminer que s'avance le
jeune courte gaudeul le mec a peut-être
l'air de rien là mais il va prendre les
matchs les plaqués au sol
bon vous avez compris là il est
l'inventeur des deux théorème
d'incomplétude l'idée de gaudeul va être
de transformer les théorèmes en symboles
par exemple le nombre y est démontrable
devient lé symbole suivant
c'est comme si on s'amusait à réécrire
tout molière en symbole elle fixe grâce
à ce système de codage très ingénieux il
peut maintenant faire des opérations
avec les théorèmes ce qui va lui
permettre de créer le concept de
propositions indécidable quels que
soient ces actions de départ il existera
toujours des propositions qui sont
vraies mais impossible à démontrer des
propositions indécidable ça al'air
abstrait dit comme ça mais il suffit de
lire la page wikipedia pour comprendre à
quel point le théorème est aussi carrée
que révolutionnaire la conclusion ils
soient les mathématiques sont
incomplètes à cause des propositions
indécidable soit pire elles sont fausses
et à cause du principe d'explosion elles
n'attendent que le jour on trouvera
l'incohérence qui le fera s'effondrer
c'est là que google va porter l'ultime
jeu grâce à l'ex son théorème
d'incomplétude il montre qu'on ne pourra
jamais savoir dans quelqu'un on est
c'est une énorme claque et d'humilité
pour tous les scientifiques gaudeul
détruit des de perfection mathématiques
elle qui se croyait inébranlables dans
la vérité absolue
on découvre qu en fait rien n'est
certain des vérités échapperont toujours
à la science il existe un monstre sous
le lit de chaque mathématicien qui
menace à tout moment de réduire leur
travail à néant bon c'est bien beau tout
ça mais concrètement comment ça a changé
la vie des chercheurs
soyons honnêtes les théorèmes de gaudeul
établissent les frontières ultimes des
mathématiques
rares sont les mathématiciens prud'hon
qui use les manipuler la plupart
préfèrent même faire comme si ça
n'existait pas ne pas faire des maths
parce qu'on a peur du principe d'
explosion c'est un peu comme refuser de
vivre parce qu'on a peur de la mort par
contre l'épisode se sont régalés avec le
théorème d'incomplétude ils se sont dit
ok goodell nous montre qu'un système
complexe comme les mac ne peut pas
éviter l'incertitude est la
contradiction et si on appliquait ce à
d'autres systèmes complexes par exemple
la machine biologique la plus complexe
qu'on connaisse le cerveau humain
et oui notre cerveau à cause de sa
complexité ne peut pas éviter
l'incertitude est l'erreur
voilà pourquoi nous sommes voie rapide
et fiable qu'une calculatrice mieux ça
sera en fait la source de la conscience
humaine et informatique
rends toi conte les théorème
d'incomplétude pourrait bien être la clé
pour expliquer si une intelligence
artificielle du futur pourrait avoir une
conscience qui l'aurait cru
même toi tu peux utiliser cette heure m
et ça peut être très pratique dans ta
prochaine interrogations de
mathématiques
si tu sais pas répond tu peux toujours
tenté d'écrire en l'absence de
précisions supplémentaires sur
l'axiomatique utilisé selon le second
théorème de gödel la proposition est
indécidable et ton prof ne pourra rien
dire sinon de mettre un 20 sur 20 et
enfin disons le les mathématiques
préfère s'imaginer trouver quelque chose
qui les détruira plutôt que de ne plus
rien trouvé du tout genre il n'y a plus
rien à découvrir en mathématiques
c'est finalement ça la plus grande peur
des mathématiciens alors qu'avez vous
pensé de cette vidéo je suis moi-même
mathématicien et je voulais vous montrer
par cette vidéo que cette matière est
vraiment shonens et pas des calculs
chiant sur une feuille
il ya des guerres des enjeux des
révolutions et c'est ça que nous aimons
dans notre métier si vous voulez
d'autres vidéos sur les maps pensé à
mettre un petit pouce bleus et vous
abonner à la chaîne saillens trash quand
on voit sur les stades que ça vous plaît
que vous êtes engagés dans la vidéo est
sur la chaîne voit ça nous donne le
signal qu'il faut continuer dans cette
direction qui j'espère vous plaît merci
à tous surtout monteur qui ont fait un
tas formidable c'était matagots aïnés
oxis ciao
il